Is there a detox homeopathy product for arsenic?
There is
Yes, there is let me let me look real quick
It is
See the detox lacquessons is on back order
And
The melcom
Let me look
Hp
Let me look here real quick
The
Attics that's the one you can think of
So the addicts, let's see if it has no it doesn't
If you want that I can make it for you
Don't think I think that detox lacquessons from PHP hasn't but they're on back order
So if you want call Megan and I can make you that so I can create the whole your path for arsenic for you specifically
So there's call Megan in the store tomorrow
Oh, yeah, she'll probably still be there for a while today, but you call her and tell her that we talked on the zoom call and
Remind her and I will make you a bottle for arsenic